so nice to meet you Alex I'm so excited
to talk to you about this movie which
has been formative for a lot of
generations myself included as you can
probably tell by the outfit yeah I'm
actually soaking in all the awesome art
you have behind you which is like yeah
yeah you can see Brett's movie I did
yeah I reviewed it for collider it was
incredible so freaking good I got to see
it while he was just finishing the cut
and uh oh we got limited time thought I
wanted to spin off but I'm like a Bowie
fanatic so I was like you could have
literally just like had a shot of his
shoe for four hours and I would have
been happy but what a great movie oh my
God same absolutely but to kick into the
questions here I wanted to start off by
kind of talking about how formative this
film was for kind of an entire
generation of horror fans but I was
curious what was was there a horror film
that was formative for you either before
you made Lost Boys or something that has
come along since that's sort of changed
the way that you look at the genre yeah
I would I mean I could came up I was a
cinephile and I loved like early Heart
Like I Love James whale and murnau and
all this sort of Silence
um and Dracula and Nosferatu and and
Dreyer's vampire and all that stuff huge
into all that
um but I think uh Carpenter's The Thing
was uh was the big cultural game changer
for most of me and my friends
um I think as big a movie as Jaws was an
alien was I think the thing really sort
of showed you the possibility of what
you could do with the genre
um and it really I think changed the
game in a lot of ways it's certainly
from Prosthetics and a practical makeup
effect standpoint
um it it it it really was spun the whole
industry in a completely different
direction and certainly as a fan it did
that too you you mentioned Nosferatu in
there a little bit and I I was curious
Lost Boys kind of set the precedent for
like this sexy vampire but when you're
watching a monster film whether it's you
know vampires or something else do you
prefer when they're a little more human
in that sense or do you prefer when
they're a little more Nosferatu Salem's
Lot kind of scary
um I like both because I think they're
different um you know I I really loved
reading Dracula when I was a kid I loved
the book
um I love Paula dory's vampire story
like I loved old vampire stories so I
think it's I don't think it's one thing
or the other I know there's like a lot
of now and this isn't my world because
I'm an older guy but like you know is is
the Twilight vampire or this vampire
like you know there's like people take
to the street and fight this stuff out
um but I like both uh but I've always I
did what I liked about Lost Boys when I
read it was that Joel was leaning in to
a lot of where the vampire stories had
come from which were very erotic and
kind of sexually ambiguous and those
things were not new they were he he
married them to what was going on in
that world in the 80s with fashion and
music but this idea of vampires being
that was what and that's to answer your
question you don't get that from
Nosferatu right you get that a little
bit from uh James whale's stuff but uh
because there was a sexual stuff going
on the background of his movies
um and I like that about Lost Boys I
like that Joel was leaning into that and
that kind of thing has influenced
obviously a lot of contemporary horror
now particularly something like stranger
things where you get that same setup of
you know it's the young gang of kids
that has to save the world not
necessarily the adults and I was curious
what it's like for you someone who kind
of set out and helped create that sort
of subgenre of horror what it's like to
watch those projects be made now
specifically with such a nostalgic lens
being cast on the 80s as a decade yeah
it's interesting I mean I I I think it's
incredibly well made
um I don't connect with it probably as
much as other people do because it is it
is one step removed from the source
which I literally lived I didn't read it
I was just there you know what I mean
um uh so there's a Nostalgia distancing
for me a little bit with those things
but uh I love that people are I love
that people are using the 80s now the
way we used the 40s when I was young you
know I think that in film is great or or
storytelling and I think stranger things
is great because they kind of take that
era and they use it to speak about
what's going on today through this lens
of the past and that has tremendous
value
um I was also a really big Stephen King
fan growing up and I think that stranger
things is probably in my opinion like
the best interpretation of what it felt
like to live in King's Worlds at that
time I've never really seen anything
else that's plopped me down in the space
the way stranger things does in King's
brain and kind of to follow I guess
Stephen King and the sort of General
horror scene you just wrapped on a movie
called destroy all Neighbors which is
coming to shutter next year and I was
curious you've spent a lot of time in
the last couple of years working on
documentaries you did YouTube effect you
did Zappa why the choice to go back to
acting now and why the choice
specifically to go back to horror
um you know I I started training again
about a decade ago uh knowing that I
wanted to do some more acting uh we got
Bill and Ted off the ground I got to get
back in Prosthetics which is you know I
don't know what it says about me but one
of my very favorite things in the world
to do
um and I come from theater that's where
I started um on Broadway and I came up
doing very crazy character work
um as kind of my sweet spot I like
Cinema or storytelling's ability to be
subversive and I don't mean that like
necessarily thematically just
artistically and horror and comedy have
the ability to to kind of punch through
various
um areas of culture uh in a very
powerful way
um and in a very artistically liberating
way
um so when I did freak that was kind of
what we were going for with that back in
the early 90s a lot of Prosthetics sort
of mix of horror and comedy I knew I
wanted to do something else that was a
mix of horror and comedy and so when
Jonah Ray Rodriguez and Josh Forbes came
to me with with destroy a few years ago
I was like yeah I'll come on board I'll
play this character I'll see if I can
help us get it financed I'll produce it
with you guys
um and it is a really I'd say a very
fresh and inventive take on a physical
effects driven horror comedy is a lot of
really funny stuff in it but there's a
lot of Gore too so
um and I'm buried in Prosthetics just
it's just awesome as somebody who is a
massive fan of practical effects and
special effects makeup I am very glad to
hear that I love I love seeing practical
effects but I have one last question for
you and it's kind of a silly one but
since the Lost Boys is about vampire
hunting if you had to go up against one
kind of famous vampire in a fight who do
you think you could beat
anyone from Twilight
there wouldn't really be much of a fight
I think I would just go boo and they
were all right
awesome well thank you so much for
talking with me it's been an honor
thanks and I'm not giving my address all
the hate mail I'm not gonna get okay I'm
only joking I'm joking